this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
welcome to EE 380 Stanford computer
systems lab colloquium fall 2012 2013
I'm get I'm Andy Freeman the other
course organizer is Dennis Allison since
this is the first class of the quarter
do a little administrivia the course
requirements are satisfied entirely
online at watd at stanford edu basically
all you have to do is convince us that
you watched each of the talks and a
quarter um this is not hard but if
you're behind in dead week we can pretty
much guarantee you're not going to catch
up so we had a lot of experience with
this we don't even do and completes
anymore cuz nobody ever finished um so
please keep up in almost every case you
can view the talks online so you don't
have to come here um that's a huge
mistake because nine times out of ten
something cool happens after the cameras
go off and since there's value to a live
audience to the speaker I'm okay with
that you're here take advantage of it
today 2012-2013 big data is an add on
101 talking about social graphs customer
behavior the web traffic in tokyo and so
on today's talk is about Big Data
classic namely models of physical
entities and processes in this case the
oil industry this kind of data predates
the web while be asleep however it's
still huge it's still incredibly
valuable and arguably there are more
opportunities for those of you who are
typical standard students looking for
big scores as a start-up today's speaker
clock clock is
stanford researcher involved changing
how the oil industry deals with their
big data look any seconds let's see can
everyone hear me the speaker on ah
should be they okay you shouldn't have
played with it I didn't touch it okay
okay well uh yeah anyway I can talk real
loud so I don't really need it so today
I'm going to be talking about as he said
big data in the oil industry and i'm
sure i would guess that considering your
computer scientists as any of you ever
taken a single geology class oh we have
one technology girlfriend so i'm going
to give you a explanation of how oil is
formed that would upset any geology
professor at Stanford but just to give
you a basic idea what we're doing here
so what you need to think about is that
we have lots of different types of rocks
in the earth if you've ever been to the
southwest you can kind of see you see
red rocks and brown rocks and they have
these different properties and there's
only really three types are really two
types of rocks we care about when we're
talking about oil and 1 i'm going to
call a source rock which has a whole
bunch of organic material and i'm going
to talk about sort of a cap rock or a
top seal the big deal about this one is
it porosity and permeability are low so
it's going to stop flow so what you're
going to see over time we're going to
get this organic material given the
right pressure and temperature
conditions is going to turn into oil and
that's my little black dots and over
time those little black dots are going
to flow up now it's working for sure
flow up and it's going to be blocked by
this top seal so oil the oil finding in
kind of the 1860s involved finding a
hill putting it all well on it and
drilling down it was that it was that
simple so it you know and
in for about 70 years that's all we did
was basically find hills where other
people had found oil and put put down
drill a well so this is a picture of
actually one of the first wells in the
United States from the 1860s and it
actually turned out to be one of the
most productive fields ever in
Pennsylvania okay so that's that's how
we're going to start we're going to
start with the 1860s and I'm going to
work forward from there so by the 1930s
things weren't we were running out of
hills or at least Hills we can see and
this is a picture of what's called an
anticline and you can just think of an
anticline as a hill underground so you
know at some stage you had some pressure
that pushed this this what used to be a
flat layer into this anticlinal
structure and then over time a bunch of
sediments came on top of it so you can
no longer see your hill so there had to
be a way or what what was interesting to
the Geo scientists of the period we're
to try to figure out a way to see Hills
below ground and that's what started in
the 1930s sighs the seismic reflection
method so I'm going to go over how we
nowadays almost all oil is found in the
world so you start with a model of the
earth and this is a really simple model
of the earth I just have velocity and
have two of them to call a flat earth
yes two kilometers per second here three
kilometers per second we always put
trees so you know this is the surface of
the earth and then we make a big boom we
use diet you know this is dynamite then
it was all dynamite they would actually
set off some dynamite at the surface of
the earth and they would record what's
happening so we're going to put that
we're going to kind of put this dynamite
at a location then we're going to
measure the ground motion of the earth
at several different locations and these
are what we call geophones and what I'm
going to show you is a computer
simulation of Earth of a source being
source generating an acoustic wave or at
this location I'm going to
have a go down and see how it goes
through the earth so you can see here's
here's kind of a spherical wavefront
that's coming down I'm showing you these
blue lines represent kind of raised so
that's sort of constant angle when they
hit this reflector they some of the
energy propagates through but some of it
goes back to the surface and we record
it so i'm going to show you that movie
again but this time i want you to watch
the panel over here in this panel is
what rerecorded at the surface so now
all we're getting right now is kind of
the what we call the director rival
which is energy coming directly from the
source along the the ground surface I
mean but eventually what we're going to
see is this I don't know what the lights
on if you can see it real well but
there's an event right here that's
coming up and we're going to see it in
our data right at this location so
that's kind of that's that's the type of
data and we do this a lot we're going to
do this experiment over and over again
and how many times we do it and how big
this data tends to grow up I'm going to
get to in the talk but this is what our
data tends to look like when we have
done a process called my great migration
whose job is to take all these
recordings we make at the surface of the
earth and somehow make a picture of the
earth and if you've never seen with us a
picture like this it's going to seem
really weird but you can imagine that at
every change in rock type in the
subsurface a reflection is going to
happen now that reflection is not going
to we're gonna we're not putting in a
we're putting in a band limited signal
so you can imagine that reflection is
going to be convening to the earth now
in addition we can we unlike kind of
when you're doing an MRI we can't put
receivers and sources everywhere we
can't very a source way down here so
we're not going to do a perfect job
being able to recover the picture of the
earth and we have one other huge problem
to kind of make this picture of the
subsurface we have to know the velocity
and that's something we have to estimate
from the data we collect so we tend to
make pictures like this really we have
3d pictures of the year so I'm just
showing you a slice out of it and these
data volumes can be very large so this
is a picture of one of the very first
seismograms from the 1930s and you can
see there's at this stage about six
recordings and you barely see these
white lines coming at and they were
using in the 1930s that to kind of get a
picture of what the to find these
anticlinal structures under the earth ok
now I'm going to I'm going to go forward
another 40 years and I'm going to tell
you how things changed again at let's
say they didn't find all the anticlines
but they found a lot of the anticlines
so the next thing was to actually get
better and figuring out where there was
actually oil so i'm going to show you
another little geology lesson here now
this source rock that has organic
material also it's going to have some
water and one of the things that happens
is when this this the the fluid flows up
the oil will tend to be above the water
now that's going to introduce a strong
reflection coefficient so if we get a
strong co flexion coefficient we can
actually see that on our data and
believe me this seems very obvious to
someone that's spent years looking at
this the this right in here and right in
here are higher amplitude events in the
data and those higher amplitude events
can correspond to a oil water contact
which can correspond to some place to
drill so that was the that's what we
were doing up to the 1970s 1980s well
the 1980s on has seen a dramatic sort of
change in the amount of amount of the
sort of the volume of data we're
collecting and the complexity we're
using to trying to form pictures of
years and a lot of that happened has to
do with how most of our most of the
large oil fields in the united states
have been found in or in the ocean
recent
and salt causes us nothing but problems
and let me try to explain why so salt
this is a picture of a model of what the
Gulf of Mexico looks like and you can
see sort of the blue colors are low
velocity and the hot colors lay our high
velocity so right here you can imagine
this is about 1.8 kilometers per second
versus 4.5 kilometers per second yes
some looking down through the water or
else the water is right here this is a
huge this is a you know for plum or two
kilometers of water right here this dark
dark blue the sediments have
approximately the same velocity as the
water to begin with they increase with
depth here you can see that the salt
body is almost touching the the surface
of the water no this is salt this is
actually huge salt bodies in the earth
they're all they're all over the Gulf of
Mexico and other locations throughout
the world and what I'm showing you now
is a model of propagating energy through
you know from this point to the surface
this red line here shows you sort of how
long where we put our recorders and this
is where we start running into problems
if you've noticed a whole bunch of this
energy didn't go up it went this way now
that all that energy going that way
means that we're not going to record
energy from this we're not going to
record very much in for energy from this
location in the subsurface which means
we're not going to be able to make we're
not going to be able to do a good job
estimating the velocity to make this to
make our image and we're not going to be
able to produce a very good image so
this is kind of in the 1990s a lot of
our work was to find salt at the core to
find oil at the edge of this salt that's
because when this salt comes up the salt
comes up from down here it tends to make
these beds tilt up the salt acts as a
seal good look
for oil so it's the same idea the salt
is a cap rock you have sediments that
get to or you have fluids to get trapped
by that cap rock things so that was kind
of the 1990s and the 2000s have seen
even more of a problem is as our targets
have shifted from the edge of salt to
undersell so all the complexity at the
edge is made even worse when we're
looking trying to form a picture under
these salt bodies and we have a real
problem because most most of the energy
and we only get energy from below the
salt at very small angles if we have
kind of a standard recording geometry so
this is kind of where wheel industry has
been moving really in the United States
and North America in the last 150 years
yeah this this can be this can be 10
kilometers yeah it's quite big now I'm
going to so I've just talked about
geology lessening I'm not I am far from
a geologist I probably take more jelly
corset geology courses than you but it's
never been my favorite subject but I'm
going to start talking to you and about
now is the data we acquired so what I'm
showing you here is a plot and this is
offset X and offset y and this is kind
of where we set recorders versus where
we have our source location so you can
imagine we have a source here dynamite
we have lots of cool sources we put we
have we do dynamite we have big thumper
trucks that we vibrate on the ground we
have air guns in in the water I you know
if you're talking smaller scales you
I've shot I've shot guns into the
substrate into the earth to make waves
and I've hit I've hit metal plates to
put in sound waves we do a whole range
of stuff in here but we put a bunch of
recorders and I'm going to show you how
that how kind of those recorders have
grown over time now here I'm going to
start with the 1930s and we didn't put
we had very few recorders that six was
the example I was showing you the
pretty close to the source and there's
another big approximation we made we we
only put we assume the earth was 2d and
we only put recorders sort of along a
line into the 2d now as time moved on we
you know we're now to the 1970s the
number of recorders increase you can see
we went all the way up to 48 and the
kind of the distance between the source
and the receivers increased plan view so
this is this is a weird view this is
take the source location taste were take
where you have the GF of the receiver
subtract them in a vector sense all on
the surface of the earth so in the 1970s
our cables got longer in the 1990s we
decided to buy the 1990s we had decided
that the earth was actually 3d or a
better put it we think we accepted the
earth was 3d and we accepted the only
way we were going to make good pictures
the earth was to accept that the 3d
nature so instead of kind of having a
single k of cable we started having
multiple cable and that meant we started
having boats that had cables that were
four kilometers long and they may have
three of them all and we would be
pulling these for you know um a 50 mile
square region sometimes well not maybe
that big but pretty pretty close so we
ended up seeing this offset range grew a
little bit in this Y direction and got
longer in this X direction and that
receiver count started going up as the
90s progressed to about 2000 basically
the number of cables pulled pulling
behind these boats increase the length
of these cables increased and the
receiver count starts going up even more
the last 10 years has seen a dramatic
increase in kind of the number of cable
the number of channels we're using to
record data as we figured out that we
can make substantially better pictures
in these complex areas if we're willing
to go to sort of to expend more money
for all intents and purposes we're
starting to have multiple boats and a
survey and we're starting to fill
in this panel so that receiver count
you're seeing is 25,000 said which is
not a typical now yeah sir if they're
actually for club are there four feet
four meters down you know just the guns
happen to be for me to put their close
enough yeah it's ahead of whom in sonar
technology you where the Navy and sonar
technology are there different they're
aiming for different things they're not
equivalent is any contracts the way to
some for some things yes the oil
industry it had the technology in the
oil industry some of it is totally cool
they have they have self-guided robot of
vehicles that will go and put these
recorders at the UU v's that were no no
not self-guided so underwater vehicles
that are able to figure out where they
are and slowly guide themselves down
with virtually no power and put put
receivers at the let's that the ocean
bottom I mean we've got some really cool
weird stuff that that people spend a lot
of money on um some of them have the day
out a lot diameter of 21 inches which is
about San of a torpedo tube yeah maybe
there's a reason yeah but so anyway I
was saying that says a receiver count of
25,000 now that 25,000 doesn't sound
like much but we're going to go and
record for 14 seconds at two
milliseconds and we're going to do that
at same experiment hundreds of thousands
of times for one survey why do you do it
so many times but part of it is we are
trying to make a picture of an earth of
that's 20 30 kilometers by 30 kilometers
long and to really get a good picture of
it we've got to do it every 20 30 meters
in X are in y or x and y so you're
moving the excitation yes we're moving
the boat that you can imagine we're
moving a boat we're actually now are
moving several boats they're going here
and then turning around and going
through this entire this entire
super-resolution working on that the
receivers stay fixed the receivers in
marine are being pulled on large cables
behind boats so they stay fixed with
respect to the expectation to some level
we have things called waves that screw
us up you know waves will pull the cable
yeah you know we have lots of things it
messes up we also get shark bites on the
Cape we get we get lots of interesting
things going on on our cables but now
I'm gonna give you the growth and the
data sighs I'm going to start in 1990
but this is a weird shark so I I work
one of my hats is I work for the imaging
group it's at Stanford and we get data
from the oil industry but we get a
little bit older data so a data that's a
few years old but that's easier for me
to figure out kind of go and look when
we got a data and this size of it and I
want to show you the growth over the
last 20 years in 1990 we were gettin 2d
data sets and they were in the hundreds
of megabytes in size when by about 1995
we had our first data set with these
multiple streamers in 3d and now we saw
our data we're starting to see a data
volume of tens of gigabytes okay we got
more cables and we started getting
larger the data set we got in in 2010
was our first multi azmuth data set and
it's now it's still a teeny BTW data set
as far as well industry is concerned is
about 30 terabytes so we have really
large data the oil industry is dealing
with data sets that are half a petabyte
in size fur sur now there's another
promise I said we're trying to make a
picture of the earth so we've got that
we have some cost it's not just really
large data unfortunately we also have
the cost of making that picture of the
earth which we're doing in more and more
complex ways so here notice this log log
linear scale I'm going to now sort of
multiply that by in by the cost of our
algorithms and I'm going to do it in
kind of a naive way so if we're really
stupid I don't know how we implement
them in you just do kind of a
straight-up count or
straight memory read sense this is how
the picture goes so you can see from
1990 we've gone from this cost so I
don't know I don't want to count the
orders of magnitude increase its a lot
if we kind of normalize that to 1995 you
can see that we're dealing with you know
between 10 and 100 thousand increase in
the cost of making the picture of the
earth so and I wanted to give you a
comparison on some things you're
probably a little bit more used to just
to show you how expensive in comparison
our things have grown so this is kind of
a standard disk size I want to found a
whole bunch of ads for computers going
back quite a while and here's the growth
of pc disk size over that time now
here's pc disk speed here's here's kind
of clock speed of a 386 a 486 Pentium
Pro woodcrest nehalem now you notice the
turnover point we multiply back cores
again that looks sort of right and now
let's compare them all so this speeds
increased about a couple hundred and
twenty times since 1994 a standard
simple disc not scuzzy in 1990 just a
standard disk disk size increased about
20,000 speed versus core is in thousand
range the stream benchmark you guys all
know what the stream benchmark is maybe
not stream benchmark is how fast you can
read continue to contiguous blocks of
memory so it's increased quite well our
data size is increased at about 10,000
times and our data size x imaging well
that's kind of off the chart and that's
our problem we really have started using
more and more cycles over time and we
were using a lot of cycles back in
nineteen ninety so another way to look
at this how bad our problem is is come
on
and my computer's decided to freeze on
me that's an interesting come on well
we're going to wait a minute to see
completely freeze time has stopped
moving according to the computer okay oh
we got some life and I have nothing ah
I've got something okay and oh and what
happened okay so let's start this again
tick tock
I am dead in the water I'm going to
assume it really hates that slide anyway
well this is coming so what I was going
to say is that basically what we're
doing now is far from what we want to be
doing we have seen we are right now have
a target that is about 10,000 times more
expensive than what we're doing
currently so we have a big need for
coming up with ways to actually make our
algorithms faster and we have life we
have life I'm getting off that side real
fast okay the higher the resolution the
classic defining for know that it's not
faster the it's it is the target is
getting more and more complex the only
way we can make a good image is actually
start is to acquire more and more data
and use a higher and higher
approximation of the correct visit every
you know this is a whole bunch of ways
we get a picture of the earth we know
that every one of these even this one
that's 10,000 times more expensive is
not accurate it's still an approximation
for the image but does that mean the
higher the bear the image it's the only
way with Acuras for all or isn't it
little resolution that after that where
we're far from it we can't right now we
have a resolution of below seldom let's
say 40 meters we need a resolution of 5
10 because we're drilling wells from the
surface and if we if we kind of miss
that's 50 million 100 million dollars
down the drain not some of them we're 40
meters is pretty big
you know Teddy meters is pretty big if
you miss kind of the that's what you
also have the problem you may run into
something that kinda Kyle causes a well
to explode you really need to have an
accurate picture of what the subsurface
looks like this way yeah yeah the I mean
so this is just showing the kind of the
growth we've seen in the evenin even in
the last few years so we're just seeing
this rapid growth in technique in the
knees so now I want to kind of give you
a few how sort of interesting stories
here in the 1940s or 30s there was a
company called gsi is anyone you know
the GSI story huh gsi was a seismic
company that in the 1940s got a bunch of
government contracts to do something
that actually didn't work for seismic
then those guys turned into texas
instruments so the green building you
see on campus that's that's one of the
founders of Texas Instruments he's
actually geophysicist now here's another
one you guys who invented the FFT hey
Dookie cooler what year was that written
57 or 60 64 then just drawn up in case
yeah well actually Chevron was using it
in the 50s and it was a trade secret and
the first this the first clustered
seismic processing was actually in like
1989 1990 so we've been doing stuff with
technology for quite a while in this
group's is specifically at Stanford I
wanted to show you some of the computers
we played it we actually had the second
unix license at stanford before oh yeah
you helped get for a pdp-11 we moved
onto vaccid then we moved on to a sem we
had to see it 1 connection machine one
we had a CM 5 we had we had a power
challenge we built our cluster I gave a
lot of blood to actually building that
cluster and in in the 2000s it was kind
of recognized the growth of computation
within their science and they started a
new center for help helping people
a shin and through some donations from
son and kind of in the late 2000s we
started a new consortium that sort of
worked on oil industry problems and
technology so this was kind of how get
getting talking to in a cloak with a
closer relationship with a bunch of
providers of technology on how we could
actually improve and speed up our
algorithms and in some cases gave ideas
that's how that how those architectures
can be changed to better service so the
latest and greatest nvidia card remember
there's two of them one of them was
co-designed by someone in the oil
industry because our needs are that
great we buy that many of them and now
the growth in sort of the need for
computation in their science we've about
increased by a factor of 30 or
computational power in the last seven
years and people are still complaining
that we don't have enough and we have a
lot of lot of things going on in school
of earth science as far as computation
seismic imaging which is what I do
reservoir flow multiscale multiphysics
simulation geostatistics computational
geo modeling global seismology
earthquake source mechanisms ocean
modeling it's just a subset of all the
things that we have going on the ones I
most you know because of I've been
involved in kind of computation for
their industry for almost 20 years now
so I'm going to really concentrate on
those and i'm going to show you this is
kind of some of the things we do in the
oil industry we seismic images we have
gravity and magnetic we have reservoir
flow and these you can think of this is
really dealing with wave propagation
diffusion fluid flow and here are kind
of the the core kernels for those
algorithms when we can write those
kernels in a different way we're really
doing convolutions FFTs in sparse matrix
sparse matrix vector multiplies that's
that's what we're dominated by
because our our stencils are not large
enough they don't win it's not even a
close competition a pencil yeah but so
the what we're convolving with is a
stencil that it's like a Jax Jax tensile
okay we're gonna and it's maybe 15
points long or in each direction and if
you go and do the if you compare that to
an FFT implementation it's not even
close in speed comparison and believe me
we've done those tests ad nauseam yeah
it's because FFTs are slow so anyway so
I'm going to talk about three different
types of platforms here the first is
kind of a cpu and i'm going to repeat
the same example where I'm applying a
second order difference you guys should
all know how this works in this honest
on a cpu we're going to kind of load
things from some memory level into
registers we're going to scale add
multiply and to get performance we're
going to go in and we're going to try to
maximize the pipeline minimize the
number of RAM accesses versus cash
accesses and nowadays we're going to use
vector units if we're going to paralyze
this we're going to go in and split this
array on two different course and see
what type of speed we can get on on a
GPU has a series of different memory
levels from shared memory that's a lot
but that's very fast a global memory
which is big but not big enough as far
as we're concerned to to kind of the
memory on a machine if we're going to go
and apply something like this on a GPU
we're going to put in into shared memory
to kind of maximize our performance
we're going to break up out to different
different threads if you're on a GP
you're going to kind of trying to have
more threads and cores to hide memory
latency all this stuff you probably know
or you will at some stage take a program
in class on GPUs and learn so we play
with these and the third one is a little
bit different and we play with FPGAs and
we put we actually did we had someone
from a big oil / oil services provider
here for a couple years and he did this
big
we sent out one of our core codes to
everybody we could find that blue did
anything with FB GS and said how fast
can you make this this was this company
Mac seller was the only one that got any
decent speed that couldn't could beat
our good cpu code by any factor so and
what they do is they have a completely
different model of how to do computation
and this is data flow so you you know
forget your von Neumann programming
style you have to accept a different
programming style and I'm going to just
kind of go over their programming style
pretty quickly here so their whole idea
is you're going to flow flow data from
some attached memory so they're going to
play put a whole bunch of RAM on an FPGA
are right next to an FPGA card and
they're going there and the comp
computation is building these compute
units that are going to do a series of
steps you can think a big pipeline and
your data is going to go flow from here
do a bunch of work and flow out and I'll
give you an example of that Oh important
thing that they have which really gives
us which is one of the reasons this is
actually useful some for some of our
application is they have FPGAs have
what's called block rama and on big
FPGAs they have a lot of it so we can we
think of this as temporary storage of
you know a couple megabytes that you can
access at a terabyte per second so it
can be really useful for some of the
things we do so kind of as an example
I'm going to flow an array that's one
two three four five six seven out of
this memory I'm going to build a series
of compute units one's going to multiply
by negative two and a couple of ads and
we're going to kind of flow the data
through this and we're going to have
we're basically building a built big
pipeline and what what the FPGA enables
you to do is if you have a big enough
pipeline even though it's clock speed is
really slow if you've pipelined a couple
hundred long this this suddenly even
with that low clock frequency can be a
big winner and there's another thing
where it can be really interesting is
these compute units can be think
like compression and decompression which
can pay off for some of our problems so
we just flow it through and to get good
performance we maximize pipe length and
we maximize the use of the block Ram
when it's appropriate so I'm going to
give you my architectural view in a
couple different ways from simply a
geosciences perspective we've got one
way to look at things as is in terms of
pipeline cores and hurts and if you look
at this you know you've got Intel
running at two gigahertz a little bit
faster a little bit slower it's got 16
cores plus vector units pipelines of
about 15 nvidia a little bit slower huge
amount of course pipeline it depends if
you can how much of the GPU stuff you
can actually use and you've got things
like mex heller which is running really
slow has you know a few chords depends
on your application and you can have
really large pipelines another way to
view this which is often more important
is if you really trying to get
performance a lot of performances how
much of the stuff how many reads can you
do in a fast memory verses how many
reads you can do in a slow memory for
art for app our applications so here's a
whole bunch of here's kind of the fast
memory sizes and how it's kind of a
couple of different memory levels on it
on and tell you can have a really big
main memory but you peel it pay a big
latency penalty and decent size fast
memories small shared memory on and on
on a fermi card but you know it's it's
quite fast and you pay a penalty if you
have to go to global and the FPGA again
as I said has this really large fast
close memory which can be useful so what
we found is and i'm going to show you
sort of examples of this the more random
the access the better if you're running
on a standard intel to win compared to
the other two you really don't want to
random access anyway but to win
the large memory can be quite useful in
a lot of applications and you know it
has but it has and when you can't get
that much from pipelining and
parallelism this may be your only choice
if you do it for us GPUs the more data
parallel the better the more memory band
limited the application the better and
if hiding memory latency can help and
you can do it that works pretty well for
Mac seller large pipelines if you get an
advantage with this large closed memory
it can be good and compression and
compression can be a big friend in a lot
of the stuff you do that so that's where
we can we sometimes see a big a big game
if you can compress the stuff you need
to read from memory by a factor of 10
it's hard to compete with an FPGA
solution if that's a big if in some time
so I'm going to show you a series of
examples here then the one I'm going to
spend the most time is from called
reverse time migration this is like the
the way this is the colonel we use for
imaging seismic data now then i'm going
to talk about kind of the advantages and
disadvantages of some of the tricks we
make to make it ekkatt economical and
how those play on different platforms
and i'm going to talk about some sparse
matrix vector work Interactive
pre-processing interactive d blurring
and I'll end after that so reverse time
migration in a minute so if you remember
i showed you waves propagating to the
earth reverse time migration that's what
we're going to basically do what we're
going to do is say here's a we have some
model the earth and we know where this
the this we injected energy from
dynamite or thumper truck truck or
whatever well we're going to form a cube
or a multi-dimensional space so in this
picture it's a three-dimensional space
in our real problem so that's x y and z
so we're going to kind of take this and
we're going to advance it in time the
wave field in time so we're going to
have a sourcing function we know what
source we put into the earth or we hope
we do and we're going to add
ansset in time and how are we going to
do this we're going to look at the wave
equation which is it's really not
showing up for anyway well we're looking
we're going to look at the wave equation
which is basically saying second
derivative and time or with respect to
time equals kind of a spatial derivative
times the velocity squared we're going
to turn that time operator that time
into a time difference operator put all
the knowns on one side all the unknowns
on the other side and now we have a way
to advance this wave field in time and
we're going to do this kind of forming a
40 volume of XYZ and time of this wave
field wavefield propagating so once
we've got that form we're going to do
something else we're going to do where
the reverse time comes from we also
recorded some data we now know where we
recorded it and we're going to say well
we recorded this data at four seconds at
these locations and we're going to
inject that into our earth model we're
going to notice that this wave equation
we can put the knowns as giving us t
plus 1 or we can put the knowns as
giving us t minus 1 we do either and
we're going to run time backwards so
every what we're going to do is we have
this data we're going to inject into the
model the what-what energy we recorded
at let's say three point eight seconds
we're going to propagate everything else
in our model and we're going to film
another cube going from t max 20 then
our imaging condition is going to be
taking the slices that are at the same
time and multiplying them point by point
though our imaging condition looks
something like this sum over all our
shots sum over all times multiplied
source and receiver at every vector
location X to give you an idea on op
count here so I'm going to op counted
memory reads if you're stupid if you're
doing something really stupid are about
the same order so I'm going to talk
about them as the same thing so first we
have the number of shots then we're
going to have
that our volume size we're going to have
the number time steps we need to advance
we have to deal with stability concerns
which you're going to mean we're going
to have to advance it a finer sampling
that we really want and we're going to
have this stencil what you're going to
use to advance the wave feel and that's
going to have a certain number of
elements so that's going to be our cost
now if I put if i can put numbers to it
those are some typical numbers so 5 12
15 10 to the 17th so that's not a small
number we do not run this on our iPod so
we spent some effort trying to get the
cost of this down for some strange
reason you know we you know we actually
want to fix you have an image at some
stage we do this a lot of different ways
one is as I said everything is
maximizing close mug things in close
memories and how you do that you do
domain decomposition so but our problem
is kind of different so you would think
this is normally how you do demand
decomposition make big rectangular
blocks and go on well we've definitely
tried that you could also think of doing
pencils and if you're you know and if
you think about those we have these
overlaps if you notice these things
overlap and that's because you need a
domain decomposition we have that filter
it has some width and that width is
going that kind of any of the samples
that go and that boundary have to set be
sent to want more than one block if we
look at sort of kind of a on trying to
fit things in l2 on a standard problem
size we may have fifty percent rereads
so that means how many elements have to
be read by reread by more than one block
using pencils and thirty-five percent
for boxes but we do pencils and I'll
show you why because you don't need to
think of your problem is static so what
we're going to do is this is this is how
much we can afford to put an l2 cache to
compute the wavefield at this location
well as soon as we're done computing the
way field at location
we can dump on this row we can dump this
entire row read in the next row and we
can continue this process all the way
down so we're actually doing pencils all
the way down and that's going to give us
the best reuse so this is just basically
flush cells that you no longer need and
to give you an idea on the performance I
stole this from one of the students this
is his work on writing code like this
over time and he started with a serial
version and increasing no seat that
should be course as he went on and
really where you really see something
interesting is the GPU he learned how to
use shared memory how to do pencils and
here what's his performance again so
this is why using pencils is kind of
important to us so now this is kind of
linked with something else which is that
our filters and there's we have a
problem beyond kind of just stability we
also need to be concerned with
dispersion and you can probably see if
you follow around this this this oval
that the wavelet changes it shouldn't
this is from numerical dispersion and we
don't like that that messes everything
up and there's a couple ways you can
solve this problem you can do smaller
time step smaller grid cells and live
with it or you can do a higher order
approximation of your difference
operators so instead of a three-point
stencil you can make them bigger and
here's kind of why you should go and do
that you use a higher order stencil the
volume size for the same level of
dispersion decreases and it's
substantial we're going we can decrease
it by a factor of eight but there's
always a penalty to get everything you
do and you have to consider the amount
of reads you're going to have to do
because the reads are going to increase
as a stencil size increases but that's
again the naive way to think about it
it's it real what really matters is
reads from an expensive memory so I just
added another line here can anyone see
it it's right here this is the reads
from expensive memory
if you know because we're putting
something in a cheap memory it's not
costing as much but this is a certain
cheap memory this is the FPGA block Ram
so this is saying because we have a
really large cheap memory we can kind of
reduce the we can kind of get away with
these really large stencils if we look
at a GPU you can see at some stage right
around here it suddenly becomes a bad
idea that's a much smaller clothes
memory and a cpu is somewhere in between
basically it has a turnover point right
in here so you know that's it that's a
game where an FPGA is the best if that
if that trick is useful for you another
one kind of at the other end is variable
sampling we have this stability and
dispersion constraint the stability one
is a function of our time sampling and
the velocity and hour on the hour
spatial sampling what we can think about
doing is changing our sampling when we
have lower velocities we can use smaller
cells we get higher velocities we can
use larger cells now this is again a
question of data data parallelism we as
we move from a CP to a GPU to an FPGA
the size of those blocks that that
become something useful must increase so
on a cpu you can make you know these
blocks quite small and not really pay a
penalty on a GPU you still need to cut
you know 10,000 different parallel tasks
to get decent performance on an FPGA you
don't really want to change much of
anything so it's a kind of the other
argument the CPU can work with this
better now another way to use a large
cache is what we call cascading remember
that CFL factor we have a whole bunch of
imaging steps or steps where we have to
propagate the wavefield we don't care
and we can play tricks by saying well at
some stage as we go through this this
volume and we've advanced the wave field
when we reach this location right here
we now have everything we need to start
advancing the way feel here and we can
kind of do this
cascading and this this allows us to do
lots of different time steps at once we
pay a penalty of needing a larger kind
of close memory in size and we're going
to do more compute but if you're really
made if you're bound from the cost of
reading from main memory it's it it's a
nice trick and the way FPGAs are growing
it's the only one that's really
increasing the size of their clothes
memory it's something that's useful
there now there's another big difference
between what we do when we do a physical
experiment and some of what we do is a
computational experiment the
computational experiment has boundaries
we've got to deal with those we don't
like those so we have to introduce a
boundary condition and we can introduce
an absorbing boundary condition which is
that's pretty simple that sort of dance
wave feels something that tries to kill
slopes that are at a certain angle to
the boundary or something really complex
these this is the best going down in
quality this is the least parallel going
up in quality guess what you you're
doing a cpu you but you're going to do
pml GPU fpga this is kind of a store
that repeats itself so here's the rtm
cost with these tricks and a couple more
than i mentioned we're basically 100
times faster we now have something we
can actually use now there's another
problem that I didn't mention and I
don't know if anyone caught it I said
we're going to advance this wave field
and then we're going to advance this
other one in the other direction and
we're going to correlate them that means
we've got a store this way feel now how
big is that way field a billion points
that you're going to do a thousand time
steps and you're going so you store in
this two-disc your speed of disk is slow
you've got a problem so we go in and I
just want to so that's kind of shows you
this speed versus speed is core and it's
getting worse so we've come up with ways
to go about finding to solve that
problem one of the things that we've
come up
with his we store checkpoints and redo
computation but we also have played some
games and i'm going to show you one of
the games we played so this is that
imaging condition what if I introduce
noise to that imaging condition well I'm
stacking overtime thousand i'm stacking
overshot 100,000 if I introduce random
noise it's gone so can i play a game to
actually do introduce some random noise
they'll do me some good and that's what
I'm going to show you here so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to say well
what would be really nice is if I could
propagate this all the way to the
maximum time and then propagate these
two fields simultaneously now I don't
only need to store a few copies of these
wave fields that'd be pretty good so
when can I reverse my propagation well
as soon as I introduced all those
boundary conditions I just show you I
can't do it anymore because those are
going to kill all the ways that go to
the edge I can think about being a
little tricky and this is how I'm going
to be tricky I'm going to introduce this
bizarre boundary here this boundary is
going to get more and more random as I
get to the edges so what is it going to
do to the wave feels how's that look for
a messed up picture so this is a wave
field advancing in time and it hits this
boundary and suddenly becomes randomized
now here's the cool thing this is the
way field at 3.6 seconds I can take that
wave field and reproduce this picture to
machine precision by going backwards and
all of those errors for my doing my
imaging condition here's using kind of a
standard way here's using that random
matter they stack out so we can play
games so the question now is who wins
and the answer is everybody nobody all
three of these these type of
architectures are being used in the oil
industry for this type of problem and
all three have their people that are
sure they're the best in the world and
it all depends on what they're doing
details
so now let me go through some quick
other examples so sparse matrix vector
multiply this is the one that I don't
think I have any applied mathematicians
makes them cringe so I'm going to do
this one first so this is a this is
showing us the sort of the range of
sparse matrix our sparse vector or
matrix descriptions from something is
very structured to unstructured and as
we go along this way our costs go up per
element because we're going to have to
use more more bites to describe each
element in that array we're going to
have more indirection a lot of bad stuff
is going to happen to us so one of the
problems we have a lot of problems in
the oil industry that involve sparse
matrix vector multiply and these are
kind of a couple of them this is a fluid
flow problem and this is the
geomechanics from so this is trying to
you know show how the earth changed over
time and this is the these two of these
are two codes from schlumberger I stole
this slide and they show its performance
as a function of course and the thing to
notice here is it doesn't scale well and
it's really obvious to figure think of
wife you're doing as far as matrix
vector multiply you're doing a lot of
reads for very little math you're you're
quickly running out of memory bandwidth
so it they sent this problem to this
company Mac seller and this is this was
kind of an interesting result what they
did is it said okay I'm looking at this
matrix it does have a lot of structure
it's not perfectly diagonal but it's
pretty diagonal why do i why am I going
to begin with why am I storing how off
it's from diagonal as a 64-bit integer I
can score I can store it as a forbidden
integer doesn't really you know whatever
works so that was the first little trick
and then they did another trick and they
said well I'm solving an inversion
problem at early iterations why do I
need to use a very high precision
numbers why don't I start with low
precision numbers and go and increase my
precision over time and that's what they
did and this is the speed up they got
basically they were seeing in the orders
of
you know 20 to 50 times faster and then
a conventional CPU node that's
completely constrained by memory
bandwidth and the funny part about this
even with all these tricks they're doing
in compression it still was memory bound
memory bandwidth bound they're doing
they're doing a conjugate directions
type in version problem yeah yeah so
that you know and kind of they like this
picture which is basically saying take a
rack do a no don't really care but it's
just an interesting way of thinking
about where FPGAs can help now another
thing that I haven't really discussed
too much as other things we do the oil
industry we have a told you all these
things are really op intensive we have a
whole bunch of stuff that's not so op
intensive and we tend to do this in a
really stupid manner and that in its for
historical reasons basically we have a
process we run a huge data set through
it we look at three percent of the data
see if it's good and when we screwed up
we rerun it again you know that's that's
tense or we take we do something even
worse we window it out to a test find
out it worked there and then it screws
up somewhere else we this is our model
and this is his from a historical reason
because all of all of the lot of our
processing systems were written in the
90s when it first became well written
and have been expanded greatly but I
written the 90s when it first became
reasonable to store data on disk rather
than tape so things have changed since
then here's that same picture again and
specifically look at disk speed memory
speed and data size and I'm going to
have a look at it a different way to and
that's showing that basically if we take
the RAM versus disk speed we've seen
Rams speed increase order of magnitude
more than disc x.x speed and well yeah
so compare that so it was a factor of
like 12 then it's a factor of 100 now or
more and we sang beta saw
eyes increase of them you know it's
increased by significantly less than an
order of magnitude and what does that
mean one of the things you can think
about doing is using main memory as a
large buffer we can never hold our
problem in main memory it's just not
going to happen you know they're not
going to put by the time they invent a
computer that can hold 100 terabytes
we're going to be doing 100 petabytes
that's just reality for us but we can
kind of start to do stuff that's
interactive and that involves kind of
building a dependency chart to figure
out you know if we want to display this
pixel and we're doing these operations
what we need to read from disk we can
kind of do games like this and i'm going
to show you an example that but we need
to think about hardware considerations
we're going to send my random access
it's going to be read dominated because
we're going to read from disk do a bunch
of operations we were displaying it on
on the on the on on the image to as far
as I owe from disk it's all read it's
going to have limited parallelism so
guess what platform we decide to do this
son any guesses cpu yeah but we run and
did a little twist we got something
called eco ram that is dead but it is
cool for this application anyone know
echo ram is eco ram was solid state
memory plugged into a processor slot and
this is why it was cool for this example
this this is kind of semi random access
of a large volume so we have a half a
terabyte of this sitting around and
here's kind of disk speed versus ram
versus the solid state and it's a heck
of a lot closer to ram than it is to
disk so we're putting a bunch of we're
putting you know half a terabyte of data
which for the application i'm going to
show you is more than sufficient on this
very fast memory and we can now play
games with it so this is the showing you
locations of sources on a 3d survey so
it rids that reads it from disk and then
we can go it displays you know this is
it this is it displays about a million
of the 10
ten hundred millions different locations
in here and we can interactively play
with it and if we decide we did
something wrong we can go and tell it to
redo it it rereads it from this very
fast memory and can go back so this is
kind of one of the new games we've been
we've been playing with recently flash
memory it's flash memory plugged into
course it's it's really kind of cool
stuff for us it's a we got about three
years ago but we still use it for some
applications like this now another one
is what I'm going to describe is d
blurring really it's an imaging method
but what we're really trying we're
trying to you can think of it as d
blurring we've got an image and we have
we net we can know that we have a
deblurring filter that kind of looks
like this so if i take the row of this
matrix this is my the matrix i want to
invert we have shelters that look like
this we can go in and if i zoom into one
of these it looks something like this
and we're going to try to solve an
inversion problem which is basically a
bunch of multiplications of a point are
filled with functions that look like
that your filter no it's actually it's
it's it's the it's the end you can think
of as a blurring operator of migration
that's that's that's what it it so if we
can invert this our images will be
higher resolution that's that's that's
the goal of it one of the things you can
notice as I'm showing you a movie of
these der blurring figured filters is
they're very smooth so this is the
deblurring filters over XY and Z and
they're smooth functions so if they're
smooth you can up sample them compress
them do types of lots of different
things and we can compress them quite a
bit we can compress them to the point
that we can hold portions of them in
things like shared memory and because
we're decompressing on the fly we can
you know have a reuse factor of rereads
of shared memory of 30 X we can do
linear
interpolation to go beyond that and this
is an application that works really well
on gpus rather than FPGAs because the
bandwidth for our GPU is three to five
times that for an FPGA it's better than
a cpu because the compute level we're
doing here visit this is like if you
want to have something that makes a GPU
look good this is a problem mix the GPU
look good it's incredibly data parallel
and it's it involves a ton of reads from
shared memory which you control so the
computer can't screw you up by sending
them out of l1 or l2 cache it works well
for us and we can get you know from what
kind of the initial CPU code to getting
the best cpu co the GPU is another fat
another factor of five or so anyone that
tells you GPUs are a factor a hundred
yeah there's something wrong but so
overall that's about a 30 speed up so
I'm running out of time so I want to end
with a few things so what I've talked
about is sort of how geoscience and high
performance computing have been together
for a long time it used to be said not I
could not find a reference this but I
used to hear this all the time that a
quarter of all cycles in the world and
from nineteen ninety four 1990 wire for
the oil industry and the second biggest
users of cycles before the internet
resolution was oil industry could not
find the quote for that but I you know
that's that's what people say we play
around with a lot of toys I get to play
around a lot of toys I would get you
know I'm getting there I have a knight's
ferry coming in this next week you know
we we get toys all the time so we get a
it's really fun my job is really fun
because I get to go and any new hardware
I think would be fun to play with I can
get someone to send it to me and get
access to it and the oil industry they
send it because they know the oil
industry is a big pot of money and you
know if they're willing to experiment
now I also that you know anyone that in
my opinion anyone that tells you the cpu
GPU or fpga is answer to everything
hasn't
enough different types of problems there
isn't right now there isn't a clear
winner and you really need to think
about how you can fit your algorithm to
different architectures not just be
stuck in this this mindset of here's my
algorithm I'm going to always do it this
way there's really the fun is figuring
out how you can completely change it to
fit something new do some of each yeah
so kind of I and this is this is what to
really kind of do this you have to
understand Geoscience you have to have
some knowledge of computer science you
have to be able to do some applied math
mathematics and if you can do that in
what's called a computational
geoscientist and this is something a
kind of a growing field here and saying
this is a computer science a audience so
what they say and that what I've heard
many oil company people say is if you
come in with these skill sets we can
teach you this we have a heck of a time
teaching people that's got this skill
set to get anywhere here so there's some
kind of some conclusions yeah the oil
industry deals with large data and large
computers you know and we're when where
we say large we do mean large you know
we're not Google petabytes but we're not
far like that at the at the current
stage we don't see a winner and really
to get somewhere and to get a lot of our
problems to be practical involves
knowing at least being able to dabble in
a lot of different fields which is kind
of a fun thing you know you don't my day
is not looking at data all day it's not
look I doing computer you know writing
code it's all day I get to do all these
different things all the time and I
always have to end with acknowledgments
I I have a lot of hats here I'm I'm with
se the imaging group I'm with kind of
this I mean the manager of this
consortium I'm also kind of the
technical director of the computational
Center at Stanford so all those give me
money schlumberger I stole some slides
specific specifically from O'Laughlin
Jordan and I show
g1 data which was from a company called
tota total fina l4 total I think they've
changed their name to in this
presentation so I am two months minutes
early any questions yeah I may have
missed it but why wouldn't you just look
for the pattern that I take it you
create the image and then somebody looks
at it and decide that is all here oh but
it is a characteristic that you can live
delicate and just look for it oh boy we
tried this and it sometimes can help you
search through a very large volume but
it you know this is not my expertise a
geologist has to you know this this area
has to the it fits this geologists
conception of this is the only way I'll
could have been formed here and there
right I mean these are 50 million dollar
tests they pass they but we do do
pattern recognition you know we do we do
play those games we do try to search our
volumes we you know we we played lots of
different games to try to do it huh I'm
considering that the even Chester yes so
I didn't talk about the velocity
estimation so the velocity estimation
involves doing that migration maybe well
it used to involve doing it a few times
the way we estimate velocity now
involves doing that migration ten to a
hundred times and we have they they
there we have to actually you know they
have limited leases on these locations
so they have limited time to these
incredibly expensive imaging product
processes then to decide if there's
worth drought drilling oil bit before
their before their lease where it runs
out yeah oh you guys do mostly physical
models where they're like statistical or
sort of techniques to do it faster than
pure physical um we play with Geo
statistic what we call geostatistics and
we play with your statistical approaches
and with they are useful for some of the
things we do but sort of four-way
propagation
that they just don't apply it all do you
see any applications of like open source
like sort of cloud computing type
distributed and infrastructure like
spark I just had a meeting today with
some reservoir flow people that we're
asking if I thought they could use
Hadoop to to do some of the work that
was a couple hours ago so yes is the
answer to that we do experiment with
cloud computing problems the problems we
have they take on the fastest GPUs a day
to run sometimes so that doesn't fit the
the sort of elastic we definitely have
can have elastic demand but some of
these these companies are running at
ninety percent of peak capacity
continuously in which case cloud
computing makes absolutely no sense as
far as a sort of their science in
general you know we're part of I don't
know if you guys know they're moving
eventually going to be moving
everybody's clusters to slack that's
going to happen the next few years and
the the long-term goal of that is to
start to have an elastic cloud at
Stanford you know and that's so that's
going to be some experimentations that
kind of the university level of that
concept and well I definitely see the
need but we've priced out what it would
cost to do amazon given ought we keep
track of our our usage and Amazon isn't
within a factor of five right now for us
that's yeah yes interesting the Hadoop
question I work with a do pretty
extensively but it's great for data
management the reason I came actually is
we've been trying to do machine learning
algorithms in Hadoop and we're also
looking at GPU to doing some of the
stuff and wondering if you've done any
you know you've done most of
computational stuff but we're talking
about decision trees and other kinds the
newest GPU has some chances yeah yeah
the newest GPU definitely is something i
would i would say that maybe you know
where you have the ability to start
threads from Fred
is something I look at the guy I don't
know do you know people at Nvidia yeah
we have we've got okay love it if you
could there's a guy called paulius have
you met paulius so I'm sure he's
probably listening right now ha you on
it he's in the oil group but he's
probably I've met the group the dev tech
group you know the dev tech this is a
dev tech people the ones you want to
talk to paulius is kind of the best
reference for being able to give you an
honest answer so make sure no one else
is around from in video and you ask him
but a curiosity question about wolf Cola
I've done some work with remote sensing
in my previous life and I'm wondering if
you've done anything like using a
multiplying hyperspectral data to
identify you know but potentially
interesting areas to drill um there is
some work with that type of data to find
locations but really we normally know
from the geology approximately where we
want to drill you know so it's it's
really fine finding what it looks like
you know the targets now are several
miles down yeah so what you see at the
surface you do yeah yeah any other
questions yes so like Hulu and she has a
lot of money so do the try to design our
own chips I mean it looks like design
their own chips yeah for this kind of
computations because they for
acquisition you would be the amount of
work they do in designing their own
everything is huge for computation they
were one of them was a part or I don't
know what exactly the relationship but
they were partnered with nvidia to some
level for designing you know the other
GPU that just came out there's sort of
one they're saying for they actually say
for oil and gas so yes that would be to
treat and actually some of the work that
mac seller did actually affect it or was
one of the things that affected the one
of the change in xylene chips so the
answer is yeah we do we do talk um you
know as far as intel intel so beggar
yeah yeah so the oil industry has this
big legacy data problem and what are we
doing to get all the stuff off of all
old nine truck tape it had well okay I
was at their data libraries are really
something to see so they spent quite a
bit of money of kind of just changing
the you know updating the their tape
system and I was at the the National Lab
up in livermore right and it's a it's a
very similar situation yeah I've seen
there yeah classified table yeah so you
know it's but it's a similar you know a
bunch of pods that can talk to each
other they're doing the same thing
they've got tape stored in you know
perfect conditions in places but what
we're finding is a lot of the data we're
acquiring is changing so dramatically I
don't think the data we acquired from
the 70s is all that useful for us
anymore
you